good evening detective West something
tells me you're not here for more of my
wife's world-famous lemon where's my son
so episode 409 is entitled don't run he
attacked us in the street he took Barry
what are you kidding me faker himself
sort of kicks it up to the next level
when he abducts the flash you're not as
smart as you it is i Barry is trapped in
thinkers lair and he's been brought
there to be sort of taught a lesson by
the professor
[Music]
well let's dark gross but light Rose
what are you having the self-pity roast
I wish Oh big killer well it's finally
got a drink
woohoo I'm thrilled that she helped
everybody fight the ranks man but now
it's like I can't escape her everybody
keeps saying killer frost was so funny
killer frost just so badass I spend so
long worried that she was gonna hurt
people but now turns out people would
rather hang out with my villainous alter
ego look yeah I know what it's like to
have the evil doppelganger right but
you're not like me anyways no you're
different you're special and your
friends would much rather be with you
than with her thanks Harry
[Music]
hoho
today's a day Ralphie alone atlast with
barbecue chips six-pack Oh liquid
happiness and 10 hours a nervous
breakdown Winona Ryder Netflix engage
[Music]
what's going on what's the emergency
it's a funny story hi I was trying to
watch Netflix and you get the picture I
was gonna press that one next
so how was your honeymoon
I am supposed to be on where it's
warm
having drinks with tiny tiny little
umbrellas in them get killed no harder
to run in flip-flops
[Music]
hey everybody we got the flash midseason
finale tonight in there dropping Easter
eggs that are three levels deep so
killer frost finally has her own drink
at jitters and she's super bummed out
the killer frost is so popular with
everyone which is a bit of a meta fourth
wall break like the fans are also much
more excited about killer frost going
all Legend of Korra on everyone like she
had some really awesome scenes during
the crossover but you may have also
detected some Easter eggs from way back
in season one like we keep talking about
how much season four is referencing
season one moment like we have all this
eobard thawne stuff going on but this
scene here is actually just like a
coffee scene that we had back during
season one before he wound up killing
Cisco when they found out his real
identity so I should also say if you're
finding me for the first time just be
sure to subscribe to get everything
there'll be a bunch of stuff during the
break in addition to other DC TV stuff
like Black Lightning is coming up
there's new Titans that's probably going
to be dropping Brenton Thwaites of the
actor that's playing Dick Grayson teased
that there would be more stuff coming
really soon so I'll explain that at the
end of the video if there is a new round
of that blast ring giveaway but as
they're sitting here having copy
obviously Amunet black busts in ho ho ho
because this is sort of their Christmas
episode because it's the mid-season
finale it's a bummer that Mark Hamill
isn't doing something like this it takes
me back to season 2 when he actually
played a version of Santa Claus while he
was the trickster so before she busts in
they're having their conversation here
he's like I know a thing or two about
evil doppelgangers talking about eobard
thawne the reverse-flash so I know
there's still a thousand questions about
him but the other part of this footage
is of Barry and iris being interrupted
on their honeymoon so that's what
they've been doing for the past week I
guess they're not taking a very long
honeymoon but Ralph Dabney comes in
trying to watch stranger things that's
why he's talking about Winona Ryder
breakdown so I guess stranger things in
Netflix exist in the world of the flash
but that makes sense he also does a
Captain Picard impression so I guess
he's a big Star Trek fan most of pop
culture exists inside the world of the
flash we also got all those Hulk
references we got the Stan Lee stuff so
we also know that Marvel Comics exists
within this world but Barry and iris
and she's super pissed I'm supposed to
be on a beach sipping drinks with tiny
straws do you have any idea how hard it
is to run in flip-flops which is totally
true if you've ever actually tried to
run in flip-flops it's a nightmare
don't do it but the killer frost scene
is in the episode the honeymoon scene
here is supposed to be a deleted scene
so this actually won't appear in the
episode but there's always a bunch of
deleted scenes that they try to post
whenever they can
there was actually a belly burger
deleted scene during season one because
people kept asking how do they feed the
prisoners in the pipeline prison so they
had this extra scene with a truckload of
belly burgers but in addition to
bringing this thinker plot to a head
like actually having Barry have a direct
confrontation with him I know a lot of
you are also wondering what's going on
with Wally this season we haven't seen a
whole bunch from him he's supposed to be
going somewhere I don't know exactly
where it's going to be but people behind
the scenes have told me Wally is
definitely going somewhere it's just
everyone's like is he going to Titans is
he going to go on to legends of tomorrow
the only new character on legends of
tomorrow that I know about is
Constantine so when that show comes back
there's gonna be a two-part Constantine
episode so after we get him we can start
rallying for them to do Swamp Thing or
one of the other deep cuts so now that
he's an arrow verse character we just
have our pick of the litter of the
Justice League dark characters but I
assume that there'll be a couple
characters that they'll want to keep in
the movies because there still is a
Justice League dark DC EU movie that
they're planning at some point so what
will happen is I'll post my episode
video after it airs and then there'll be
a whole bunch more bonus videos during
the off season so if you have special
requests for DC TV like Titans or flash
videos while we wait for everything to
come back just write them below in the
comments but there will be a bunch of
new stuff dropping congratulations to
the giveaway winner from my last flash
video hero maker please private message
me so I can get your contact details
I'll announce a new winner when I post
that episode video tonight click here to
learn all about the reverse flash and
how he came back during the crossover
and click here for that brand new
Deadpool 2 teaser trailer and to learn
all about the Marvel Foxx deal that
might end up happening thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight